he caught their voices but now Brian the
boom mic guy is breaking his silence or
at least actor Chris diem and topolos
has some words to say about his
controversial character on The Office
who would have thought that a simple
boom mic guy trying to make a PBS
documentary would cause so much tension
within the office fandom okay so Chris
isn't actually a boom mic operator but
his character did cause a significant
hurdle for one of TV's most beloved
mockumentary couples but really can you
blame a guy for developing heart eyes
for Pam Beasley after all Jim Halpert
can certainly relate but after years of
waiting for Pam and Jim to get together
fans wanted no part of any threats to
their relationship when the couple
finally defines the relationship in
season 4 it's smooth sailing from
Niagara Falls and Beyond but then enter
Brian the boom mic guy who steps out in
front of the cameras to shake things up
in season 9 when Pam and Jim are
constantly fighting about Jim's new job
Looper exclusively spoke to
diamantopoulos who set the record
straight about Brian and the fans who
love to hate him at the mention of his
hotly contested role on the office Chris
jokingly apologized the actor also
agreed that seeing the couple go through
their first realistic hurdle since
coupling was nice on what he would say
to the office fans who threw shade at
Brian for getting between Jim and Pam
with such a meta storyline Chris wants
fans to realize that not everything is
perfect even in the healthiest
relationships he said first of all I
would say wake up and smell the reality
folks in every relationship you got to
put the extra work in sometimes things
go by the wayside and yeah that's
reality let's turn the cameras off
seriously guys
enough in US
and for anyone who tends to forget
actors are not their characters it's
super uncool to harass an actor just
because you don't like their character
Chris continued the other thing I would
say to them is hey people watching
screens I'm an actor I didn't try to
break up Jim and Pam I didn't do this I
was hired the last thing I would say is
you can see in Pam's eyes that she's a
little more into Brian I'm sorry she
doesn't go there but she wanted to so
you know what guys sorry but [__] you of
course if you've ever met Chris you'd
know that he has a sardonic sense of
humor so don't go picketing his house
okay Chris also wants to assure fans
that Brian's doing great he joked
Brian's living in the Turks and Caicos
He's a fly fisherman he's really good
though fans can be Savage about Brian
Chris loved working with John Krasinski
and Jenna Fisher he told Looper they are
Pros to the nth degree and I'm such a
fan of what John and Jenna did both on
the show and how their careers have
exploded rightfully so off the show I
showed up on that set very penitent and
deferential with the notion that I am
here to help if I could Chris foresaw
that there would be fan resistance when
he signed on but that's the gig I knew
that any instance where the character
pushed into the territory where the
audience might perceive that there's a
threat there would leave me the actor
probably being reviled but that's my job
as a fan of the show it broke my heart
to see their marriage in trouble but as
a professional actor I was ready to give
Jim a run for his money
foreign
[Music]